with over 300 sessions at next 2023 it's
understandable that you couldn't get to
them all so if you didn't see Enterprise
Readiness for generative AI then stay
tuned because here's the
rewind generative AI is poised to usher
in a new wave of innovation and with any
new innovation there are inherent
questions around risks like safety
security
and privacy it's an exciting prospect
but without getting answers to core
questions it could be overwhelming and
with that in mind the four key
Enterprise Readiness questions that
customers are asking are my data is my
differentiator but how can I protect my
IP while customizing Foundation
models I want to be an AI everywhere
organization but how do I deploy AI to
every employee and in every location
while keeping everything secure and
compliant I want to scale up to meet the
moment but how can I scale up with geni
specific infrastructure cost effectively
resiliently and
sustainably I need to be effective
responsible and safe but how do I make
gen work for every end user while
mitigating harms so how does Google
Cloud address those concerns Enterprise
Readiness is at the core of our approach
to generative AI with our data
governance and privacy security and
compliance support infrastructure
reliability and
sustainability and responsible AI so
let's take a quick look at each of those
questions and how they relate to those
core principles question one was my data
is my differentiator but how can I
protect my IP while customizing
Foundation
models with our data governance and
privacy you are in full control of your
data not Google in fact your data is
only processed according to your
instructions your data is also secure as
we have extensive data governance and
security controls and we stand by our
commitments to transparency and
compliance with regulations and privacy
best
practices while gen aai is new our
commitment to Cloud security and privacy
are inherent because it's built on our
cloud platform and privacy by Design and
default is built into our entire
stack we also have adapter layers that
allow you to customize Foundation models
for your own use cases while keeping
your data private question two was how
do I deploy AI to every employee in
every location while keeping everything
secure and compliant with Google Cloud
we have security by design by default
and in deploy employment including
worldclass compliance offerings with
multiple levels of encryption physical
security and ongoing security testing
cryptographically secured identities
with a zero trust model and default
encryption at
rest and suspicious activity monitoring
malware identification and encryption at
rest and in
transit and for generative AI
specifically we have VPC security
controls customer managed encryption
keys and access transparency question
three was how can I scale up with Gen
specific infrastructure cost effectively
resiliently and
sustainably with Google Cloud's
infrastructure reliability and
sustainability our infrastructure is
resilient and scalable by Design with 38
regions 112 availability zones 187
Network Edge locations and thousands of
edge
nodes we have purpose-built
infrastructure for generative AI with
various Hardware speed scaling and price
performance options to meet your needs
built with an open-source software
ecosystem all of that on the greenest
cloud in the industry and finally
question four how do I make gen work for
every end user while mitigating
harms with responsible AI we you were
one of the first companies to articulate
AI principles these principles put
beneficial use users safety and
avoidance of harms as essential business
considerations Google Cloud's approach
to responsible AI includes not only how
we develop our AI products but how we
enable our customers to innovate and
build responsibly with product and data
governance processes to align our
products with our AI principles in a
consistent repeatable
way we provide tooling and support to
our customers across the product life
cycle from Technical safeguards and
safety filters to citation
checks we also develop and share
research education and best practices
for the industry our customers and our
partners in summary adopt a platform not
a model whether first party third party
or open- Source Google Cloud gives you
the tools services and infrastructure to
make every model Enterprise ready if
you'd like to see the full talk check
out the link in the description and
don't forget to subscribe to our YouTube
channel for more great next rewind
content thanks for
watching